In previous videos, you could see we found
a waterfall on the neighbors' land.
We cleared the area around it,
and also rediscovered the lagoon on the top.
We fixed the floodgate, did some landscaping,
and tested it during the winter.
The neighbors are very happy, and us too,
but there is much more potential to it.
We want to store more water, and have a cool place to refresh.
Welcome to a new Project Kamp update!
So, we are now at the lagoon!
It seems like there is a lot of water,
but actually, there is a big layer of mud...
We're going to take this out to retain more water,
and to be able to swim in summer.
We are very happy with the lagoon,
but at the same time, a bit worried...
Because, last summer, it dried up...
So, before the dry months come, we want to make it deeper,
so it can store more water.
On top of that, we could use this place as a pool.
And, clean the thorns around it,
to make a space for us, and the native trees.
Also, we will make a little bridge
to make access easy for everyone!
And, by the way, I want to introduce you to Ale,
who is going to start the work!
Hello! I'm Ale!
I'm 26 years old, and I came with Chester from Spain,
to help with whatever is needed.
I've always liked doing physical work in natural environments,
getting dirty,and moving around.
I've been interested in community living for a while!
And, when I discovered Project Kamp,
I knew I had to come, and see it for myself!
Eventually, I would love to live long-term in a community!
Maybe, even create my own!
This is the perfect learning opportunity.
So, let's do it!
Now, the water is flushing away...
Good luck with the job!
So, now, the lagoon is empty.
We are going to join Chester down there.
Explore the area a bit more,
and see what needs to be done.
So, we can see that the floor is super muddy...
There's a lot of cane that we have to take out too...
All brambles...
All leaves, plant material, and branches...
I'm imagining a super cool beach with the towels!
Just laying there, enjoying the sun, having a swim...
Okay, enough talking!
Let's get to work!
Let's clear all these paths, and see what it looks like!
So, it's been going quite well,
with just working by myself
But, I could use some hands throughout the process...
- Perfect!
We are recording!
To access the waterfall, we have to cross this part of the creek...
As you can see, it's a bit deep.
So, we thought we could make a little bridge.
There are a lot of old native trees, that burned here.
But, luckily, there are new ones growing back!
So, with this old chestnut, we will try to make a bridge,
to make it easier and safer to cross.
We will see if our friend Jaime can do something with it.
- What?
Nothing!
I can do something funny!
Okay, so, now that this whole area is clear,
we can start digging this here.
And, build some nice places here, to enjoy the sun.
I don't know how long it will take, but let's see!
- Hello Chester!
Well, this is really full of worms!
Almost in every shovel, I take a couple of them.
Look! There's another one here, another one here...
Very good soil, so, it's a good sign!
Anything helps, Chester!
- You need to put it here.
Okay, so now, we're just making water
do the work for us, and clean all of the soil.
It's working!
Yeah, nice Ale!
I wanna see it shining!
- Shiny, yeah?
So, now, we need wood for building the terraces.
Luckily, we have a lot of mimosa,
that we chopped down weeks ago.
- Hey Sean, what are you making?
Today, we've cleared out these big rocks, that we have here.
You can use it as a seat, because the water level will come halfway here...
We just put a retaining wall to keep all this mud back
And then, we're gonna build some steps going up here,
so people can access it, from both sides of the land.
You kind of have a cool spot to sit,
and chill by the water, with maybe a cocktail.
They're pretty sturdy!
Let's move all of this!
So, now, the terraces are starting to take shape!
I don't know what this is...
So, I'm doing a spiky thing,
so we can do steps and rolls...
I'm still trying to make this wall a little bit more sturdy...
This week, we're all done!
- That would be funny as well!
Yeah, that would be funny, right?
Come on, Chester!
Now, that everything is mostly done...
We decided to clear the rocks from the dirt,
that was accumulated over the years...
To give it a final touch, Filipa went to pick
some grass in the neighbors' land.
To grow in a new area we cleared from brambles.
Now, it's just a matter of time,
and let the grass do the rest of the job...
Cool teamwork!
So, we've already cleaned all of the floor...
This wall, we made these rocks also clean...
Now, we just wait till it fills up, see if the wall holds up,
and enjoy the beautiful lagoon!
Now, we finished the work, so we invited Tonecas,
to visit and see what we did.
He also gave us some thoughts!
- Nice, eh!
We are happy that Tonecas liked our work!
And, we are also happy to find that endemic salamander!
It's a good indication that the water is not polluted,
but it was not the only animal we found.
During the making of this video,
we also found frogs, toads, birds, dragonflies...
And, hopefully, we can attract even more animals,
now that the lagoon has more capacity to store water.
We also found a lot of native trees and plants,
that now have a lot more space to grow!
Let me show you all the work, that we've been doing,
in the waterfall and the lagoon area.
Our friend Jaime cut down a dead chestnut
that we had here, and made this lovely bridge!
And, not only do we have a easy way now, to cross the stream...
We made a new space for the young chestnut to grow!
The grass, that they've planted during the winter,
is starting to grow quite high!
Really nice and smooth to lay down!
So, at the beginning with all the dirt,
that we took out from the lagoon...
We started putting it in here to make it more smooth.
And, we also built these lovely terraces, where we can plant flowers.
Then, we cleared all of this space, to have a nice pass,
and to get to the new area.
Also, with all of the dirt, that we took away from the lagoon...
We made these big terraces, where we can enjoy,
lay the towels here, let the grass grow, and enjoy the place.
Okay, enough with the small things!
Let's talk about the important part!
So, we removed a lot of dirt from the bottom of the lagoon.
And now, not only do we have a nicer place to swim,
we can also hold way more water!
And, thankfully, the wall is still holding up!
All of the dirt that we removed from there, most of it ended up here...
And, now, this place is not so nice as it used to be.
Before, this was all full of cane...
So, we made use of the space,
by building these lovely steps and sitting area.
We can enjoy the water from both sides!
So, now that the mud is all gone, a layer of gravel appears,
and it's much nicer for the feet.
And, also, it doesn't get sucked into the water.
We removed so much mud, that you can see the difference!
Before, it was below the knees, and now it's this deep!
You've seen what we've done!
Now, it's just time to let everyone enjoy the place!
Look at this beautiful place!
It has been a long and pleasant journey.
And now, everyone can enjoy it!
In the next video, you will see us renewing the yellow van
at Basekamp, to make a long-term living space.
You can see it already in our Patreon.
Otherwise, we see you next week!